i know it's
been a lot of changes and stuff
and
i love being your dad
we love you
you know i always wanted to be a father
i always wanted to be a parent it was my
main goal in life was
to have kids and i remember
like realizing i was gay i thought god i
can't have kids
how long did that thought last
like for you a little while i thought
you know how
because i thought do i just go and marry
somebody and then get out of it later or
what do i do
but i thought i can do whatever i want
to do i'm going to figure it out i'm
going to have kids
and after i had bryson
um
oh my god when i had bryson
you made my dream come true
i think it's exciting watching you put
down roots and just to get to see you
experience that again with hannah
it's really exciting
perfect segway
um
what you just said you're adopting
hannah
huh you're adopting hannah
there's a few things in the
mix
yeah
yes adopting hannah would be
a next step too
but we
actually went to
some orphanages here
adopting a baby
why do you want to do that when you have
hannah and you have other kids and i
have a future husband that may want it
and remember um armando's 32 maybe all
of his dreams aren't fulfilled either
yet yeah that's a lot isn't it how how's
it gonna work out though because it was
so hard getting a marriage license well
exactly yes it wouldn't be an easy road
there's still a lot of unknowns about it
but for the most part adoption would
take a while
you even brought up like in vitro and
all that and surrogacy too because it
um
would be a shorter process if you did it
like that
two
i'm just
i'm just really shocked i'm sorry
like you have four kids here
in the united states and then you're
gonna raise another family
be so wrapped up
with that
i don't think you can keep up with
everything if you adopt a kid you're
gonna get so wrapped up in that like
you're gonna forget about us forget
about my kid forget it forget all about
future grandkids
it's nothing about the kids that are
coming into your life like is he gonna
come and see everyone or we're gonna
have to come to mexico all the time it's
not gonna work out like that
[Music]
you